-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Here we are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, last night
President Biden delivered
his first State of the Union
address.
Biden spoke for 62 minutes.
Well, actually he spoke for
10 with 52 minutes of clapping.
[ Laughter ]
-So every child, every American
has clean water
to drink at home and at school.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Biden's speech aired on
every major TV network.
When they heard,
Netflix was like,
"See, this is why we can charge
whatever we want."
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
Biden kicked off his speech
talking about the war
in Ukraine.
And in a rare moment
of bipartisanship,
both parties
stood and applauded.
Yep. Democrats clapped proudly
while Republicans were like,
"Please don't show me on camera.
Please don't show me on camera."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, everyone seemed to be
in support of Biden.
Well, almost everyone.
Throughout his speech,
representatives
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Lauren Boebert
were heckling Biden.
Here they are right here.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
They're like the QAnon
Statler and Waldorf.
[ Laughter ]
Look, I feel bad for
the congressman
stuck in between them.
Look at that guy.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, you think the middle
seat on Spirit Airlines is bad.
[ Laughter ]
And everyone's
talking about this.
At the very end of his speech,
Biden said something that
stood out to people.
Check this out.
-God bless you all and may God
protect our troops.
Thank you.
Go get him!
[ Laughter ]
-"Go get him"?
"Go get him"?
-"Go get him."
[ Laughter ]
-Not "go get 'em."
"Go get him." Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Right after, Putin called Trump
and was like,
"Is he talking about me?
Is he talking about me?
What is "--
[ Laughter ]
Well, Senator Chuck Schumer
was there,
and he took home the award
for most poorly timed applause.
Watch this.
-Unlike the $2 trillion tax cut
passed in the previous
administration that benefited
the top 1% of Americans,
the American Rescue Plan --
The American Rescue Plan
helped working people
and left no one behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, the medical term for that
is "premature ovation."
-Whoa! Hey!
[ Laughter ]
-And Speaker Nancy Pelosi
didn't go home empty-handed.
She won the award
for weirdest clap.
Here it is.
-Many of you have been there.
I've been in and out of Iraq
and Afghanistan over 40 times.
[ Laughter ]
-Is there a knuckle rub
TikTok challenge
that we don't know about?
It looked like she was shaking
invisible maracas.
I don't know what she was doing.
And this was great -- Supreme
Court Justice Stephen Breyer
definitely won the award for
"guy who looks like the waiters
at Applebee's are singing him
happy birthday." Look at this.
-Thank you for your service.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
I mean it.
Get up. Stand up. Let's see you.
Thank you.
[ Applause continues ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Switching gears here,
Major League Baseball
has canceled opening day
and some regular season games
after owners...
[ Audience boos ]
...failed to reach a deal
with players to end the lockout,
yeah.
It's tough because that means
that there's only 900 baseball
games left this season.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, this was rough news
for fans and even more
devastating news for the tiny
ice cream helmet industry.
[ Laughter ]
You guys like that one?
Listen to this -- Fitbit is
recalling nearly 2 million
of its smart watches after
118 people reported
that the batteries got too hot
and burned them.
-Ooh.
-118 people.
How'd it get to that point?
Were they like, "Maybe the first
117 are just a fluke"?
[ Laughter ]
Usually the only time
I get burned by my Fitbit
is when it tells me
I didn't stand up enough.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
this is going viral.
Last night on
"Wheel of Fortune,"
one contestant kept trying
to solve the puzzle
with only two letters left.
Seemed pretty obvious, but she
just couldn't quite get it.
Watch this.
-I'll solve.
-Okay.
-"Another feather in your hat."
[ Buzzer ]
I'll solve.
-Okay.
-"Another feather in your lap."
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-No.
-A P?
-Yes, there's a P.
-I will solve.
-Okay.
-"Another feather in your map"?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-It was pretty fun though,
'cause during each guess,
we all felt like Chuck Schumer.